these are the miracle quadruplets now
mourning the loss of their mother
Shabnam Sadiq was just 39 years old
another victim took Ovid 19 with her
husband she left for a relative's
wedding in Pakistan at the beginning of
March her five teenagers had no idea she
would never return speaking to Sky News
her older brother said they've lost a
special person she was on the ventilator
for knew 24 days and then you know every
day we gained results back a blood test
this their things working everything's
fine so we're very hopeful and then all
of a sudden on the Monday I got the
phone call I think the best two o'clock
UK time she passed away we just can't
believe it I still I still can't believe
it to be honest with you it's sad that I
can't go take my goodbyes or you know
just to be there nearer somehow her
family say she had a dry cough in the UK
just days before she left
Shabnam and her husband didn't think
anything of it but rapidly time ran out
she wanted to see her kids cos she
couldn't breathe and she was saying look
this might be the last time I see you
but is sad it's very sad I wish I could
have spoken to her she deserves all the
credit she can get sorry she's in a
better place God rest his soul
God rests in a remote village near
Islamabad Shabnam was buried her husband
spoke to Sky News from Pakistan just
hours after the funeral she was amazing
everything was gonna happen
her death has rocked a community Shabnam
was a Labour councillor in Slough for
four years her colleagues described her
as hardworking and dedicated what
Shabnam did really well was show really
softer side to politics to show his
kinder side of politics and I think in
recent times I think there's been a lot
of media hype around what what that
looks like and I think she was the
epitome of that kindness being humble
and really grounded to do what was right
coronavirus continues its assault on
people right across the world the
effects of this death has left five
children in mourning the family is
always going to be there but obviously
your mum's your mum that's something
that nobody can replace